Um, final words. Final words. I guess
that's my role here today.
I wrote notes because memory sucks.
Before the notes, actually, I told you
yesterday morning that usually people
thank their sponsors. And in this
particular case, I wanted you to
actually find them and shake their hands
because these people came in when they
had no reason to. They couldn't get the
list of attendees. They couldn't get
talks. They couldn't get anything. And
they gave us money anyway. Especially
last minute, two weeks, a week before
the con when we had to grow into 700
people to let like 400 people off the
waiting list. These people just came in
and gave us money expecting nothing just
for the community. So if you end up
seeing any of them, I mean, Nostic is
me. You know me already, but Tech with
Kyle and honestly Kyle made this thing
happen. He's [\h__\h] incredible, right?
Ile,
White Rabbit, Hian Futures, and Alian
Ventures. Just shake their hands.
Remember, they cared about this
community without asking for anything.
So, thank you to them really. So, just
thank our sponsors. Thank people who
cared about the community.
Second bit is we are finding our our
footing. We don't know exactly what we
are. We are a community conference and
usually I keep those at under 200
people. We are now 700 people here,
eight here and 800 on the on the slack.
It's something else. There is a maybe
tooting our own our own horn horn but it
feels like a a warp point in time that
really came true here. And I'm not
saying this conference will happen again
in a year. I'm not saying this
conference will grow. I'm saying
something happened here today. And I
think it's about forming a new
community. We've seen it happen before
when Defcon started, when the threat
intelligence community started, when the
threat hunting community started, people
got together from different walks of
life, different areas in security, just
made it happen. And when on the online
show we do, Pronto, get the [\h__\h] out.
And I saw Chris English, right, and who
was executive director of the NSA and
the White House and Gary Hlip who was
CISO of SoftBank and Halver Flake who is
a legendary as far as I'm concerned
researcher and then some student
randomly coming in from Singapore or
something and everybody was talking
about Claude's context window. I knew we
have this community and I knew it was
time to do this. So people keep thanking
me and the volunteers because honestly
it's a huge effort. It's not just me.
I'm just the front, right? And I just
called myself fat, didn't I? But
regardless, this is truly a huge
community. Everybody put in so much
effort. Everybody who came in in here,
all of you put in so much effort just to
be open to talk to people. And we talked
about this. Talking to people is
horrible, right? We prefer dogs. But
truly, thank you because it wouldn't
have happened without you. And with
that, I will leave you with the
following thoughts that I wrote down
because I'm not as smart as the people
who came on here.
Here we go.
Yesterday,
I left you with a lot of thoughts about
startups needing to get to product
market fit within 3 months or out even
after they found it. And we talked about
how we are moving from quoting my
co-founder fromu from a nondeterministic
to uh from deterministic to
nondeterministic configuration and that
might that might that mean to security.
We talked this morning about coding
agents are cool but what do we do when
everybody including finance uses them
and a lot of them already do. We no
longer control it. Everybody builds
their own infrastructure. Right? So my
understanding for today is as follows.
We can't stop the storm. It's coming.
It's here. People don't see it. If they
checked it out even a month ago, it's
irrelevant. And we talked several times
about how staying on top of things,
people feel outmoded. They don't need to
be 80 years old to feel outmoded. How am
I ever going to learn this thing? How am
I ever going to keep up? You saw Daniel
yesterday coming on to show his work.
He's on the edge of this. And he feels
old. He feels like he needs to keep up
all the time. What would I tell these
people? It's no longer relevant. So we
understand now and this is from Ryan
Moon who ran stage two downstairs. It's
not I'm not that smart and I'm going to
quote him. Not exactly because I took it
from memory but being here it means
people here are people who understand
that we will have to dump our our dump
our scaffolding and our infrastructure
and all the smart prompts we built every
90 days.
That is a harsh harsh understanding that
we spent all this time just researching
and building our own tooling to be
effective when three months from now
it's almost irrelevant compared to what
we can do. But this is I don't remember
this exact wording English second
language but he said the people who are
here chose to be part of this death trap
of doom.
We really enjoy this right. He deserves
your applause. He's an awesome human
being. We chose to be here. We are
excited about being here. And a lot of
people said this reminds them of the
early days of Defcon. Not sure about
that. It it feels like we are Several
people have said this like we're in the
'9s and the odds again where everything
is exciting and scary at the same time.
The only thing I really know to say is
we live in the future. It's exciting. It
is a warp point in history that luckily
for us we get to be a part of this week.
Again, I don't know what will happen
next week or if this conference will
happen again, but I want to go over a
statement. ment a lot of people said in
2025 which was AI will not replace you a
human using AI will replace you I don't
know if that's true anymore
or for what it depends it changes just
looking at the rate of change it's crazy
and I truly believe that if as I said
when I look at companies and I'm looking
at who might survive this storm
I think that the only true indicator I
have is if the CEO is on cloud code or
cursor or copout or whatever it is,
which sounds ridiculous to many people.
And before we build an internet of
agents, I want to quote somebody I truly
appreciate from the DC area. His name is
Steve Crocker. He wrote RFC1 and he's a
dear friend
and he told me once a story about
sitting in the room for Arponet when
they're just starting to plan what will
happen and in the first meeting as they
were sitting down they wrote a lot of
stuff on paper and one of the sentences
they wrote down was networks are for
people
and I don't know if this network will be
for people for very long but I do know
that at least for now unlike in the 50s
and60s where science fiction predicted
it will have robots doing our laundry
and not playing chess. It's kind of
turned the other way around.
It still serves us. We're still
relevant. And I truly believe the way to
stay relevant is to be on the edge. And
it's so hard. And when we get on the
edge, it's so hard to get stuck on the
narrative. Oh, I have this down, but
you're already behind. So if we talk and
I I'm not sure I mentioned it before or
not but bringing it all together looking
at the nation state level people talk
about cyber power with a capital P. I
don't know what that means. I don't know
if it's Nvidia and the chips. I don't
know if it's OpenAI or Anthropic. I
don't know if it's all the PhDs. But I
do know one fact and that is this is the
level of AI right now in the world. This
is the level who knows how far it goes
where it can go gets to. This is the
level where most people operate. I
operate here because I don't just talk
to GPT or claude or Gemini. I understand
there is actually multitor and I can
chat. There is tool use starting to get
into agents.gents. There is the
robberous snake where you eat your own
tail and get your input into the output.
There is the agentic flow and the
self-healing. And you know what? If we
can get people around us, as somebody
said on stage a second ago, to not deny
this is happening, but just try it out
and get to that level here, not here,
but just that level here. If only 2% of
people we talk to will actually do that,
we can change the entire world.
Companies, countries, doesn't really
matter.
That is my own manifesto. And as I said
the first day,
my own right hand at my company and my
significant other unfortunately is alone
in the shelter right now in Israel
forbade me from ever writing manifestos.
At least until I'm one day a
billionaire. I hope not. I think I said
that the first day. But this is my
manifesto because I'm seeing this pain
in everybody here. You're all relevant.
Some of you are really deep into the
technology. Some of you are risk
executives.
But if we can just reach out and help
people just a little bit to understand
what's going on. I think that's
wonderful. And just to see the rate of
change, Rob Joyce who graced us with the
last, hey man, can you count for 30
seconds and said yes. So thank you said
do your own redeeming do your own
whatever it is. The attackers are now
facing and I mean sitting in front of
Katie who understands so much more than
me about this. I feel kind of unfit to
talk about this, but the attackers are
now facing their own
um singularity, a micro singularity has
happened. In defense, we're not there
yet. So, one of the only things we can
actually do is take that offensive power
and use it. And anthropic just came out
with this cloud code security and open
eye before that with Arvar and they
changed the name now to be codex
security or something like that. And you
have all seen what happened in the stock
market.
I don't think that was justified, but I
think it was a hint of what's to come.
I'm not saying application security
won't be here, but it will be, as Chris
[\h__\h] often says, it will be here. It will
be different. And some companies will
grow, but honestly, right now at this
stage, this has been so exciting the
past two days. We learn, we see the the
future, we see the hope, we see the
technology, we see the fear, but none of
us will be relevant. Not a CISO, not
their team, none of us. If we don't do
just one thing which is start using
cloud code today and if somebody doesn't
use it kick them and it can be cursor it
can be right now I'm a cloud code guy it
will change tomorrow although it's
religion so that's really my call to
action to everybody it's not just about
you not feeling outmoded or you being
extremely on top of it none of us can
keep up pull one or two people with you
just to this level and understand that
this community here is a community and
what the only thing that really matters
is not the talks and you can see them
online for free. It's just the people
you met because when it comes down to
it, we are people. We talk to each other
and other than just doing our work,
putting bad guy bad guys in jail, making
sure the internet can still function,
making sure things are going on, being
excited and fun and showing that people
that we're better than them or whatever
it is that motivates you in the hacking
world.
Just consider that at the end of the
day, we need to understand how and this
is trolls who used to be CS Bis once
said, I want to quote him precisely. How
do we make jobs redundant without making
people redundant? And I have no idea.
So, I'm going to focus on my own little
space of AI security. And for my own
startup, we developed a capability
exactly like Entropics. Yeah, I think
Nicholas Carlin is probably far better
than I am. Okay, but we developed that
capability. And I'm looking at Entropic
saying, Entropic just did it. I'm
looking at OpenAI and that's Dave Iel
just doing it. Who am I? And I'm looking
50 startups that got funded to do
exactly the same stuff of just let's
look for vulnerabilities with LLM sust.
And I'm saying I don't know how open
source will protect itself. I don't know
how all these companies will protect
themselves. I have science fiction ideas
of automatic patching and not waiting
for vendors and just giving up whatever
warranty they didn't give us to just
patch on our own. I see the attackers
going and launching operations and not
even trying to create zero days or
prepping for months and years in advance
but just on the fly creating them as the
attacker. Imagine all this science
fiction world and I think two years in
advance so it's probably two months out
and the the message connecting
everything that I said from use it today
get your teams to use it today don't
wait um how do we make people not
redundant how do we help people rise to
just that small level of using agents
right now all of that together in my
brain comes to people and community
and understanding that we can do things
together.
It's been incredible. I have people who
are volunteering here who are truly
CISOs, billionaires, somebody's
significant other, researchers, and they
just look to be a part. Everybody here
looks to be a part. So, I would strongly
suggest when this is done, consider
using the Slack, consider sending
messages, consider using the cards that
we created where everybody wrote who I
am, what I can do, how I do it, how you
can help me, how I can help you, just to
keep the conversation going.
And with that, thank you to Edo is stuck
in Israel. Thank you to Kyle who has
done so much. Thank you to all the
volunteers. Thank you to Aaron, to Moon.
If I start naming names, I'll forget a
lot of people. But I do want to make
make fun of one last guy. And I think
you all know where this is going. If
you've been reading the Slack at all,
and that's Drago because my god, Draos,
if you forget to turn off your mic one
more time. Isn't that guy brilliant?
creating an entire online conference
with other people who helped uh who I'm
not allowed to name, but he created an
entire online conference, not just
streaming, with multiple rooms and hosts
and whatever. And I'm I I begged him
today, please open your mic by mistake
to keep the guy growing.
So with that, on that note, today we
don't have official dinner anything.
What I would suggest if you haven't done
it already, I requested in the morning
is go on Slack and say, "I want it
Italian. I want Japanese. I just want to
go for a walk in San Francisco if you
want to do that. Keep to the safe areas.
But find other people you know and don't
know and just go randomly somewhere and
enjoy this last night of the conference
being together. I have no idea where I
will end up. Maybe in bed. Maybe I'll go
to Mills because it's close by and I can
just have a burger. But whatever it is,
that's my last call to action to you.
Actually, I I lied one more. And I know
about like five minutes ago I said it
will be my last thing but I think it
connected.
Um and my active ADHD that's undiagnosed
just kicked in and I forgot what I want
to say which is wonderful to you. So
I'll just say folks thank you so much
truly this would not be what it is
without you
and
yeah just that thank you very much.